خليني بهذه السعاده خليني بهذه السعاده
راغب واعود الى عادات شهر رمضان الكريم
يعني نحن الان على الطاوله فقط عندما نقول
رمضان وتحضير الطاوله والاهل والاصدقاء
والاقارب والزوجه ونقول ايضا الابناء راغب
اين خالد
[موسيقى]
ولؤي
ببلدهم الثاني الامارات العربيه المتحده
وتحت حكم انبل الناس واشرف الناس جيهان
انا سعيد سعيد بقدر بقدر بالمي لانه على
سفره رمضان مش عم شوف اولادي قديش هيدا
بياثر بقدر سعادتي بانه هنعرفوا اللي
اختاروا يعيشوا وعرفوا كيف يقرروا
المستقبلهم وين يعيشوا بامان
ويكونوا اشخاص فعلين بالمجتمع مثل ما اردت
الدوله الاماراتيه انه يكون الناس اللي
عندهم فاعلين بالمجتمع اليوم لؤي عم يتنقل
بين الامارات ولندن وامريكا
لانه لاي طبيعه درسوا عم يدرس الفاشن عم
يدرس المجوهرات
في كتير بمجال الفاشن عم يتنقل بين اوروبا
وامريكا وانت عم تدعمه
انت وجيهان وانا يعني شو عنا بالحياه
اليوم غير انه نسعدهم يعني انا اليوم
اعتبرني حاكم بقلب هالبيت حاكم عادل بدي
اسعد شعبي كيف عم تكسر على جيهان بهالايام
الروحانيه الهادئه اللي فيها العبادات
اللي فيها هيك هدوء النفس انك بتلاقي
بالبيت مثلا هلا نحن كنا اصدقائك بس صعبه
كيف عم تتعاطف اليوم اليوم نحن على تواصل
مع الاولاد كل النهار وبعدين جيهان يعني
الحمد لله الله رزقني بسيده صالحه